as the corona virus spreads across the
country governments are trying to find
ways to assist local hospitals this is
why defense secretary Mark Esper ordered
the Navy to plan on deploying two of its
hospital ships to highly affected areas
one of those hospital ships is the USNS
comfort it's based in Norfolk Virginia
and is currently undergoing maintenance
which will take weeks to complete soon
it'll be dispatched to New York where as
of March 19th
4152 Cove in 19 cases have been
confirmed you know we're still at the
early days of this by some estimates
folks are thinking as many as like 5
million Americans might need to be in
the hospital at some point as I manage
this having enough beds to handle that
will be really critical the USNS comfort
is armed with 12 fully equipped
operating rooms a 1,000 bed hospital a
medical laboratory and a pharmacy it
will take in patients who are dealing
with issues like wounds or other
illnesses so that hospitals can focus on
kovat 19 cases we're seeing this crazy
influx of patients who have covered 19
and as part of that you know hospitals
are getting really full the u.s. only
has so many hospital beds it's built for
a system that is healthy most of the
time but that completely changes when
we're talking about a pandemic the USNS
comfort has been deployed many times
before including to Puerto Rico in 2017
to help deal with the aftermath of
Hurricane Maria since 2007 staff aboard
the USNS comfort treated more than four
hundred and eighty eight thousand
patients performed 5,500 surgeries and
completed over 100 engineering projects
its latest deployment was to Central
America from June to November 2019
another no-man's
during a promise initiative in 154 days
it visited 12 countries treated nearly
sixty nine thousand patients conducted
over 1200 surgeries and moved over two
million pounds of cargo via helicopter
its next trip will be to New York Harbor
where it will hopefully be one of many
solutions to the coronavirus crisis